hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game uh it is a rest today in the
candidates tournament and this game is
not played by one of the candidates it
is in fact a game between anish giri and
world champion magnus carlsen and it was
not played in the venue where the
candidates turned and displayed it is
was actually played in a bar uh here you
have a nice um uh
photo of of the two of them playing uh
it's a very very cool game very cool
opening a lot of a lot of things happen
and well you you probably have seen in
the thumbnail what happens but
it's just amazing how that position even
gets on the board and also if you are uh
perhaps one of the people that are
watching
them play through the through the glass
do mention in the comments that would be
very very cool uh now getting back to
the game anish has the white pieces and
he opens with e4 we have knight to c6 by
magnus going for the names of edge
defense knight to f3 d6 and now anish
grabs the full center with the d4 we
have knight to f6 now going after the e4
pawn by magnus and knight to c3 we have
g6 preparing to fiance to the dark
square bishop bishop to e2 bishop the g7
in both players castle and now we have
d5 attacking the knight and magnus just
goes back not knight to e5 but rather
knight to b8 and now he's going to
undermine geary strong center with a
with a move like c6 so here we have h3
preventing bishop to g4 and now pawn to
a6
interestingly this position occurs quite
a lot as people do play this but c6 is
the move that everyone plays but here
magnus plays a6 and it is a move that
has only been played once before we have
a4 uh pawn to b6 and now uh a rook to e1
there is one game where bishop to a3 was
played but here on each plays work to e1
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game
so magnus goes bishop to b7 and now
bishop to g5 we have c6 finally
challenging the the center and the queen
to d2 now preparing bishop to h6 the
trade of the dark square bishop so we
have knight beat to d7 by magnus and now
bishop to f1
uh c captures on d5 e captures on d5 and
the magnus brings the rook into the game
rook the c8 and bishop back to e3 and
this is uh a very interesting
thing about this game is that how many
moves anish does with this bishop so now
bishop back to e3 and magnus could
consider even an exchange sacrifice with
rook captures in c3 to weaken the d5
pawn and after queen captures knight
captures and c3 opens up this diagonal
so black would definitely have more than
enough compensation for this but he
keeps the tension plays rook to e8 and
now bishop to d for bayanish another
move with the dark square bishop we have
rook to c7 uh now preparing to move the
queen over all the way to a8 uh put
pressure on the e on the d5 pawn and
this rook is then coming to c8 so rook a
to d1 and now queen to a8 we have king
to h1 and now uh magnus plays bishop to
f8 and when magnus makes a move like
this it definitely feels like it is the
beginning of the end uh the pawn is now
protected so you don't have to worry and
the other rook is coming to the to the c
file so bishop to e3 another move with
the bishop and rook eat the c8 we have
bishop to g5 another move with the
bishop
and the magnus goes for rook to c5 just
puts more pressure on this d5 pawn
so bishop back to e3 by niche another
move with the bishop attacking the rook
here and now magnus gives up the
exchange to to grab that central pawn so
rook captures on c3 b captures and now
not knight captures on d5 but first
knight to e4 this is even stronger
because the d5 pawn will fall and this
way you get another pawn and some some
extra cool moves so queen to d4 now
attacking the knight knight captures on
c3 attacks the rook rook to d3 banish
and now knight captures on d5 attacking
the bishop here and now another move
with the bishop bishop to g5 uh now rook
captures in c2 by magnus and rook to d2
offering a trade of bishops rook to c5
or trader brooks rook to c5 magnus
declines this and not knight to h2 now
anish wants to set up some sort of a
king side attack bring the queen into
the game put the knight on g4 have
access to the h6 square bishop to g7 and
now queen to h for by any shifting all
of the pieces into the attack uh bishop
to c3 now attacking the attacking drugs
there was no really a good way to to
avoid this and it's it's questionable if
magnus should even do this it's a blitz
game and this is your dragon you already
sacrifice material you maybe don't want
to do something like this but okay
knight to g4 and the magnus goes for the
rook the bishop captures on d2 and
bishop captures on d2 okay another move
with the bishop but this one is uh you
know
a recapture and now h5
as knight to h6 check was coming so this
way you at least give your king some
squares knight to h6 king to g7 and now
comes rook captures on e7 and here
interesting uh
about the position is that anish has 14
seconds on the clock and the magnus has
some 30 seconds on the clock
but the position is completely winning
for black it's an incredibly cool
position so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the absolute best
move for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not recapturing
right away and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is knight the
e5 this wins the game and there is
nothing you can do now uh the problem is
that you you can't really play something
like let's say queen here because rook
captures on f7 and it's game over you
get checkmated so you have to play and
not to this but knight to e5 and now not
only are you defending the f7 pawn uh
but uh
there's no good move here now queen to
d8 will be will be a huge threat and
even if f4 uh attacking the knight we
still play queen to d8 and now the great
thing about having this knight on e5 is
that you don't have to worry about rook
captures with check and blundering your
queen because after knight captures the
knight also defends the queen so
knight's the e5 just an incredibly uh
strong move in this position but of
course 30 seconds on the clock magnus
just uh picks up the rook knight
captures an e7 and now queen captures by
anish going after the f7 pawn and now
comes knight to e5 uh defending the f7
pawn like this but i will i will just
show for your amusement uh the queen to
f8 line because it's just awesome you
sacrifice a knight here and after the
queen captures now you attack the queen
again all of these squares are taken so
you don't really have that the only
square is queen to a7 and now you play
rook to d5 go after the bishop and now
uh what do you play uh
not all that much you can do if you move
the bishop away from the defense of the
uh knight we're just gonna pick up the
knight if you if you play something like
c1 then even rook to d1 is coming with
an attack on both bishops uh so best is
just to play knight captures on f7 queen
captures and now bishop the c3 check
going after the black king
king the f8 now we trade the queen
captures king captures and now bishop to
c4 this is how white remains in the game
uh although it's uh well uh who who
would see this even even in a long game
uh this would be now okay this would be
of course played in a long game but it
is just very nice king to e6 now bishop
to d4 uh with b5 captures captures and
after bishop to b3 uh king to f5 now
basically forcing white to capture
bishop captures bishop captures and you
get this position where black is upon
bishops of opposite colors uh and the b
pawn is marching forward it's a pass
pawn with the white king being so far
away uh this will be winning for black
but uh you know it's it's uh it's one
big long line that uh is possible uh but
only uh for your enjoyment this is blizz
game so of course players will not spot
such moves and knights the e5 was played
uh and now pawn ponte f4 now this is
much different uh magnus does play queen
to f8
uh and uh uh anish just captures the
bishop here because you you have to uh
you know add the defender to the f7 pawn
the knight cannot move so queen captures
on b7 now comes knight to c6 and pawn to
f5 anish continues the attack uh the
knight now again nicely defended we have
queen to e7 uh offering a queen trade
and queen captures on b6 now anisha is
still playing for the win even though he
he's lower on time
and here magnus plays g5 and now how do
you continue well anish played pawn to
h4
uh but um
or no anish played queen to b2 with
check uh yeah queen to b2 with check is
uh a very very strong move but h4 is
also also playable the point is after h4
uh you can't capture the knight here
that's that's a
very nice thing so you would have to
play something like g4 and then the
knight is protected so yeah there's that
because of course if you capture bishop
capture it just blunders the queen
but okay in the game queen to b2 check
was played now comes uh knight the e5 by
magnus and uh the position is now
completely winning for anisha here
instead of this you have to play queen
to e5 you go for a queen trade
and the magnus is still just better but
after this knight the e5 move uh magnus
is dead lost but again it's so beautiful
that you will have to pause the video
one one more time and find the win for a
niche while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredible checkmate uh with the king on
h6 and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it is queen to b8
that's the the movie that ends the game
uh the the move defends the game uh and
now the point is of course if you
capture the knight then the queen the h8
is checkmate right away the pawn
prevents the king from going to g6 and
if you don't do this how are you
preventing queen to g8 check this will
force the capture and then again queen
the h it will be checkmate so there are
a couple of things you could do you
could play queen to f8 but that's not
gonna be all that great because f6 check
you have to move away from the defense
of the queen and it's a game over that
we pick up the queen and now you get
checkmated so the only thing left uh for
you to do after this beautiful queen to
b8 move is playing knight to g6 which is
ugly in itself
f captures on g6 king captures on h6 and
now g captures on f7 preparing to bring
another queen enter game so queen
captures but now queen the h8 with check
and now you can see that you are just
getting destroyed king to g6 bishop d3
with check and now the bishop pair from
hell will do their bidding rook to f5
you have to block because the king has
no squares and now queen to d8 will be
sufficient we're going after the g5 pawn
because the rook is pinned and once you
unpin now bishop to c3 check again no
more squares so we're going to play rook
to f6 and now even bishop to c for a
nice finishing move uh there's just
nothing you can play queen to f8 you're
going to play queen captures king
captures and of course this and the
bishop player remains black has no
material so queen to b8 a spectacular
move for anish but he misses it he plays
ponte h for now that's why i thought he
played h4 in that position i know h4 was
played at some point
and now magnus plays f6 this move saves
magnus and now he holds the position h
captures with f captures and now anish
plays queen to b8 but now it's not as
strong because there is no pawn on f7
which means the black king gets an extra
square to escape to uh so okay uh uh
here uh uh queen to f6 by magnus and
this is just a weird move to make
allowing this queen to g8 move uh after
queen to f8 the game just continues
queen to f8 now you can trade for
example captures captures okay you you
will still have to waste a few moves to
go after that knight but let's say
bishop captures an a6 and ish anish
creates a pass pawn and he starts
pushing it the bishop fare will of be
escorting it it's going to be a hard
pawn to stop but here we have queen to
f6 by magnus and he misses a brutal
brutal checkmate that anish spots on
each place queen to g8 with check and uh
he was in this position on move 42 that
magnus carlsen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
so what did magnus miss here well he
missed that after king captures an h6 of
course he doesn't have queen to h8 but
he missed that anish would have bishop
captures on g5 leaving uh carlson's king
with uh without a single square the only
move left is to capture the bishop but
if you capture the bishop you no longer
have control over the h8 square so
basically we get the checkmate that we
are trying to achieve the entire game
queen to h8 will be checkmate as the
pawn covers the g6 square so incredible
stuff uh magnus missed it after queen
the g8 he resigns and what an incredible
game uh by by both of them but anisha
anish takes the win
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a little bit of uh uh you
know a breeder between the games of the
candidates tournament we uh we might
show a few more games from this uh blitz
event uh and there are some other games
that were played between some uh some
guests so we might show that but then we
are of course tomorrow returning with
the candidates tournament if you have
any of your own uh favorite games from
this event uh do share in the comment
section and i will do my best to cover
them uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it once again you can check
out the venue here very very very nicely
done
i would like to thank alan chevalier
moore uh aubry mishkovich jeffrey cook
abhishek babu and gregory thomas for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the candidates until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day